hardest thing you've gone through in
your life i mean obviously a lot but
what's the one that just resonates at
the hardest moment in your life where it
was just uh you thought
you know and i don't know what you
thought if you can get through this or
well when my smile when alicia a year
and a half ago now was diagnosed with
stage four
uh breast cancer oh
oh i'm sorry now she's clean she's clean
we attacked that that's just the most
amazing thing about alicia we are so
similar and yet we are we we we both
come to this relationship this marriage
with with a full
toolbox full of tools but neither one of
us have the same tools
because i like to say if if if two of us
are the same then one of us is
unnecessary
so when uh when a person in a white coat
told us that she was three years into a
five-year shelf life
uh in her pet scan lit up like a
christmas tree
we both and hear this folks we both
looked at each other and said
no we have things to do
not only individually but together we
have a tremendous amount of things to
to do this is not going to happen to us
we are going to figure out everything
that
cancer wants and stop it
we are going to find out everything that
cancer
hates and do it and we did
and now she has a clear pet scan
and she cancer is by the way cancer is
not something you beat
cancer is something uh i know this
because i'm the founder of the
co-founder of children's miracle network
cancer is something we all have but we
also all have
a system that is built to fight it to
keep it at bay it's like
oil and water you know it's gotta you've
got to keep it at bay
so when somebody in a white coat tells
you you have cancer
what they really are saying is your
cancer has gotten stronger and your
system
that fights it has gotten weaker or has
given up
so you have got to
weaken the cancer while strengthening
that system
how do you do that well you do it with
diet you do it with i mean people say
cancer can't live in a uh
in uh alco and in alkalinity so drink
alkaline water well yeah do that
cancer can't live in heat so
get a uh every opportunity do infrared
get into an infrared uh sauna infrared
saunas go up to 158 degrees
i have one of those cancer loves sugar
when you get a pet scan they will give
you a thing called glucose so that they
can see where the cancer is
why because cancer attracts glucose
so stop eating sugar it's not a matter
of choice it's a matter
it's a matter of absolutely a matter of
life and death
uh there's something about cbd oil
that helps i don't think it fights
cancer but i think
it takes your system that is there to
fight cancer
and gives it something it can recognize
and that system goes oh thank god you're
here where you've been
and it enables that system to get
stronger
it enables i believe it enables the
medicine that the doctors will give you
to work better so the second that person
in a white coat walks in
and says these things your mind you
don't i mean do you get emotional do you
start going oh why are you just turn
yeah i mean i can't even think about it
without without getting him because i
mean i was there
and um alicia puts it this way she said
for
for the first couple of days let the
house be on fire
you know you woke up in the middle of
the night and there's there's flames
down the hallway and there's no way to
get out except jump out the window and
it's three stories okay we'll live that
way for a couple of days
don't don't deny yourself
the cleansing
of panic but don't
live there you can't live there
it almost sounds like she's consoling
you in a way she's like saying hey this
is
like almost she's like she was i don't
know there's
this inner strength where i think i
would just fall apart i wouldn't and
she's like hey this is it's almost like
you guys jumped into a plan like we've
got to get this let's grieve let's
we panicked we panicked and uh you know
all these
all these long-term goals i couldn't
look at it couldn't look at a tree i
couldn't look at a flower i couldn't
look at anything
without wondering if she was going to be
here